e
I'm I'm going to go ahead and open the
the hearing it's a work session of of
division three uh we have nine bills
that we want to uh have to U sent out of
here with recommendations today is our
last day it's got to get go to the full
finance committee so we've we've been
talking about uh these nine bills for a
while uh and and today is uh just we're
going to we're going to be finished with
our decision not because the decision is
ready to be finalized but because we've
it's time to finish so um we're going to
be out of here at
2:45 uh we've got some some hot fresh
amendments coming on
1573 so we're probably going to do it
last um uh and uh so uh um Mr Ripple if
OS wraps up the amendments to 1573 while
we're talking are you are you going to
be informed I believe so yes I'll and
I'll print them out obviously and hand
them out I'm not sure if that's going to
happen for both amendments in the next
two hours and 45 minutes um I might have
to hand out drafts if it comes to
that all right okay it obviously it's
better if we have the real thing but
those we were working on those kind of
late um all right so with that in mind
uh on Monday we had three bills that we
thought we were comfortable with um uh
locking down with
recommendations those three were House
Bill
1564 we recommended an OTP on that house
bill
1282 we locked down an otpa with that
and on House Bill
1593 we locked down an Opa on that is
there anyone in division 3 that would
like us to reconsider the decisions we
made on
Monday representative Earth did did I I
want to make sure you heard the question
um of the three that we decided on
Monday 6482 93 are there any of those
that you would like to have us
reconsider today or are you okay with
the decisions we made
Monday 1564 OTP 1282 otpa 1593
Opa so I'm I'm just being careful here
uh representative priest uh thank you Mr
chair uh speak chairman I'm sorry um
after yesterday um I would like to
reconsider uh HB
1595 uh we will I I'm just doing things
in chunks okay so so that'll be a great
segue okay okay so I'm not hearing
anyone wanting to revisit those three
that we we concluded on Monday which
brings us to House Bill
1595 we uh on Monday we took an
otpa recommendation on a 7-2 vote is
there anyone that would like us to
reconsider
1595 representative priest uh I would
like to for us to reconsider 1595 would
you go ahead and speak to that what what
what do you think the issue is in your
mind um the issue of
uh of abuse domestic abuse um that's not
adequately covered in
1595 could could you elaborate on that
is the way we amended it it's it's a for
there's a formula there that's supposed
to simplify and help the the the courts
determine um a appropriate shares I I
don't see there's any mention of
domestic abuse in the amendment for
1595 and and how would you have it
included what and what I if if you'd
like to turn it over to representative
tersi that that's okay that would be
great all
right thank you very much first I just W
to
say thank you to the division for giving
me the
opportunity to um look at this one again
I apologize I have actually written
remarks um because I found as I was
discussing it with different people I
was getting a little emotional about
this topic so I appreciate your
willingness to hear me out as I just
would like to say a few things about
1595 um as chairman Edward stated in an
email to us earlier this week he I had
spoken prior to our last meeting about
concerns that we both had with House
Bill 1595 and I had agreed with chairman
Edwards that there was an interest in
pursuing interim
study from my review of the proposed
amendment for 1595 I was not convinced
that it was the right path to move
forward with that
one while House Bill 1564 is already out
of this Division I think all of us can
agree that the two bills have been tied
together in a way that it's impossible
to speak about one without the other
what concerns me is that I have had the
feeling that because they had similar
fiscal notes and that both dealt with
child support that they were being
treated as very similar bills with only
minor differences that could be easily
addressed and
combined we heard from the beginning
that house bill 1564 was a no-brainer it
came out of the policy committee with
unanimous recommendation and to pass the
house unanimously and the level of
agreement on this bill was clear and
passing it was the right thing to do on
the other hand House Bill 1595 did not
come to this division with such a clear
path the policy committee had been split
and the house had a divided vote on the
bill we received many emails um
discussing the use of parenting time as
a factor in the calculation of child
support and it's my belief that the
parenting formula makes things more
complicated Waypoint a highly respected
advocate for Children and Families
stated this change would likely result
in lower support amounts for lower
earning parents likewise New Hampshire
legal assistants concurred with this
fear that lower income earning parents
would be the ones
affected most often parents who are
victims of domestic violence are the
lower earning parents who struggle with
poverty the amendment to House Bill 1595
that was passed still relies on
parenting time and that in and of itself
is inherently problematic in cases of
domestic violence or situations of abuse
anytime that parenting time is fully
connected to a dollar amount it turns
kids into ponds it turns parenting time
into a currency by declaring what that
time is actually worth in domestic
violence cases it enhances the
controlling nature of the abuser with
ways to take money and the
kids even in cases where domestic
violence is not an issue but there is
high conflict where parents don't agree
on anything it becomes a competition
with the children in the middle both of
these
instances would include parents taking
parenting time that they previously may
have had no interest in didn't have time
for or
misused this doesn't protect or look out
for the welfare of
children we do not want to set a
precedent where our state values
monetary importance over the importance
of the healthiest possible upbringing
for our children it will lead to the
courts having to be more involved
because of the ongoing issues it will
perpetuate we heard that these bills
could live in harmony together but I
disagree because of the concerns from
several stakeholders that 1595 does not
put the well-being of the child first I
still believe strongly that we should
consider a motion of interim study where
we can do some serious work and dig into
how we can address these concerns and
while I don't really expect I'm going to
be changing anyone's thoughts minds or
votes
today I would like to thank the division
for giving me the opportunity to explain
my objection to the action that had been
taken earlier this week thank you
representative
wer the bill came to us as figuring out
parent time and dividing it and what did
it cost you're trying to introduce a
whole new topic which is not this policy
in this committee it might be something
that needs to be addressed but it's not
something that
we're dealing with what came to us and
and if we make a a change to it it
should be based upon how it affects the
money spent and not say oh you left out
this and you left out that that should
go back to Children and Family Law and
that should be a bill they they bring to
us not having us do some policy change
to a bill that's before us thank
you thank you well I appreciate that
comment I think I have seen some
adjustments to policy work happen in
this committee and um I am simply
expressing my concerns and objection
over the vote that was
taken may I ask you a question do do you
know if there's a companion bill to to
um 1595 that's coming out of the senate
or and the second question just so you
know them both is if there's not would
would you would you commit to continuing
to work with the Senate so that they
hear your
concerns cuz we're not done right this
is just a house
position I actually don't specifically
know I don't know if one of The
Advocates knows if there is a a senate
version of
this
um I would be I'm I'm not seeing anyone
raise their hand or anything so I think
that's probably a good conclusion so so
then the second one would just be if if
uh if this were to pass the house 1595
as amended would you be willing to
continue to work with the Senate because
they'll they'll be picking up this bill
and reviewing it well I do know that um
having spoken to uh representative
priest has spoken to representative
maiori who is um a person who has been
supportive of 1595 uh he expressed
interest in joining a working group to
work on this um as well as
representative Greg
um if that's not possible I'm sure that
they will be following the bill over to
the Senate
also just so you know I did get a couple
messages from uh representative Greg
this morning and she's very interested
in your in supporting your position on
this uh representative
hle thank you Mr chairman um thank you
for sharing I could tell from the tone
that this this is a tough bill um not
having been there right I haven't lived
through some of the heartaches that
various families have both here in the
committee potentially as well as um the
citizens of New
Hampshire and I think I think you make a
a valid point about not trying to use
the children as pawns right that we
don't want to weaponize government at
any level um I could probably easily
speak and become very emotional about
how I can see government weaponized in
some form and then children become um
become the darts that families use
against one
another I think there's an element under
this that that might be happening anyway
unfortunately and we do need to account
for the real costs that happen when you
are taking care of a child for some
period of time and I think there's an
element of some and I my background
being in in the math and science Fields
I always think about things that are a
lot easier if there's an equation that
kind of defines what the rules are so my
natural bench is to go that way and I
think there is value here in
establishing some criteria relative to
Parenting Time and costs I think those
coupled together if you are in if you
have one of your children with you there
are real costs that happen and maybe I'm
missing something and if I am missing
something about the EXT the actual
direct costs that are incurred when you
are overseeing a child please let me
know but I think coupling those two
together has value the weaponization
side needs to be fixed that's a
completely in my eyes that's a
completely separate issue because we've
allowed government through the family
court system the way it's structured
today to have one spouse challenge
another and to use the children as a
means to attack their former spouse and
I would love to fix that it's an it's an
important issue because I've seen as
we've made as we've made government more
powerful in the management of these
relationships easy it is easy to to use
government to be the baseball bat to
harm the other one including the use of
the children so I mean I haven't
experienced this personally in this
domain but I I I sense the pain and I
can feel the pain from you that you're
sharing is there any way to that we can
even with this bill with an amendment to
stop weaponizing the government side and
to decouple it from the cost side
because I think there is the cost that
we have to deal with right that's the
finance side of the bill and we want to
make sure that the parents that are
overseeing their children and have them
in their care are compensated for that
time CU if it is split 50/50 that works
my understanding today is some of the
formulas are are very disadvantage are
are are not fair and if there's someone
in the audience please correct me if I'm
wrong but I understand that when they
start doing income comparisons there are
times where it is really disinvent is a
advantage to one family over the other
the way the structure is done
today and someone can speak to it
representative Leon lay on lay on nice
and plain not fancy I'm getting closer
thank you Mr chairman um I'm the
chairman of the special committee on DCF
this issue of weaponization of children
especially around this would be a very
very important topic for us to work on
and to dig into to be able to look not
just not in the context of a bill but
large large at this issue I would really
appreciate you coming and joining us so
that we can talk about this because I
see that special committee as an
opportunity to work into these
underlying issues that are harder to
address when we see a specific Bill
coming to us but we have a chance to sit
and talk through those different issues
and bring people in and I think that
that would be very valuable work and I
think I I would really like to ask you
to come and work with us so that we can
figure out how to deal with the issue of
weaponization because whether we pass
this bill or whether we inter room study
this bill that's still an issue that's
going on so let's try and tackle it as a
distinct issue um because we need to
figure out what we can do to to stop
that are there further comments from the
division on this uh and for those
sitting out here wondering why I haven't
gone to you this is a a work session
this is the time where we're really
supposed to be talking to each other
about our vote votes and uh and so if
there's factual things that we're saying
wrong I'm interested in factual
corrections but we're past the point of
opinions so um representa
Stringham thank you Mr chair um you know
just just my perspective on this in in
light of both bills um you know both
bills had strong proponents
1595 has PE has people who very
concerned about what the implementation
of 1595 might mean might mean for
families uh in my view that was uh a
topic that was uh discussed in the floor
it's a matter of policy uh 1595 passed
by over 50 votes it was not a straight
Partyline vote you know very very close
and um uh the discussions that we've had
here in committee as well as discussions
I've had outside side uh I think there's
been meaningful efforts to make sure
that if both bills are passed that um
that there's no uh inconsistency that
can't be uh fully implemented so then
you know uh and um uh you know I think I
think the issues of whether this is good
policy or not is still there um but in
terms of the house I think the house has
spoken on that issue at this point and
so the issue really for for me is about
Finance if um and
um uh with
1564 um being being passed and um on a
unanimous basis or near
unanimous uh I I don't see any
implementation costs of1 15595 that we
have to deal with uh so um I appreciate
that the that 1595 has been amended so
that there's no difference in definition
that are used so to make it simpler for
the Department to implement I do expect
there to be a vigorous debate about uh
whether this is good policy uh in the
Senate and the continuation part of the
view but I think in terms of the job
that I've been asked to do um I'm going
to uh I still will support uh aop pass
on
1595 represent torski I just I just want
to be clear that I am fully aware of the
amount of time that we've put into this
and I thank everyone and I thank the
people who have been working with um
both the policy committee and us on this
I don't need to dig it any deeper um if
we were to take another vote I would not
support the opop pass as amended similar
to the other day my preference if the
opop pass as amended did not pass would
be a motion of interim study um but I am
fine with moving it along so that the
division can have a final um
position to bring to the full finance
committee so I I think we should go
ahead and entertain a fresh uh motion on
House Bill
1595 uh and this would obviate what we
said in work session on Monday regard
depending on how how the vote turns out
but I would entertain a fresh motion uh
on uh House Bill
uh representative wer or walner rather I
wer
walner begin with W end with yeah and
sometimes we share thoughts did you want
to make a motion yes I want to make a
motion um for 1595 to be interm studied
is there a second
second um all right any further
discussion would you do you want to
speak to that motion or are we ready to
just take a vote I think I think we've
discussed it are you ready to take a a a
vote on a motion to interim study I
would be happy to Mr chair all right
thank
you uh the bill is 1595 the motion is um
interim study
um representative Lon
no representative Earth no
Representative hle no representative
Wier no representative w
representative
tersi
yes uh Stringham votes no representative
priest
yes um chairman Edwards no vote is three
to
six with that motion failing is there
another
motion representative whole I'll move
aut pass is there a second with with the
amendment that was already the am with
the amendment that we
yes is there a
second yeah representative Earth is
there a second second second okay let me
know when you're ready to take an otpa
and the amendment is the one we voted on
Monday I think it was in my name but I
referred to it as the Hutchins
amendment I just want to make sure I got
the amendment down
OTP uh this is uh 1595 is amended
1172 representative Lon
yes representative F yes representative
hle yes representative Wier no
Representative walner no Representative
tersi no Stringham votes yes
representative priest no uh chair
chairman Edwards uh yes
63 okay um and that was so
with that I think we're ready to move on
to uh House Bill
1363 my note here says uh consider an
amendment by representative torki do do
you have an amendment for us I
do thank
you
am I recognized to speak to the
amendment or uh yes thank
you
um
this amendment was drafted upon the
guidance of um the department
where uh we wanted to clarify a few
things about the employee assistance
program um I don't have the highlighted
Parts in front of me but I'm pretty sure
we added in the current members of the
general court and household members
shall be permitted to participate I'm
pretty sure that was added in there and
then there was a line added at the end
nothing in this section shall be
construed that members of the general
court are employees or otherwise deemed
anything but members of the legislative
branch in order to clarify that we are
not employees and do not fall under that
whatever that umbrella might lead to um
which was one of the concerns uh raised
here in division um and
finally the amendment changes the
effective date pushes it way far out to
January 1st 2027 to be clear that
um there would be uh no apparent benefit
to any one of us as we are not sure who
who would actually be um in the general
court in 2027 to take advantage of um
the program so um the prime sponsor um
reached out to me after the hearing to
say this is the preferred amendment that
she wanted um and asked me to file it so
I presented to the division for
consideration and I hope you'll be able
to support it because I believe it
addresses many of the concerns if not
all the concerns that were brought up
thank
you is there any further discussion
representative Stringham yeah I'm I I I
did hear that I you know I thought the
idea of having this fairly inexpensive
support available while we're all uh
incredibly strong uh uh and you know
talented people that can take care of
ourselves this still things sneak up on
people even even uh top people like the
ones I have the pleasure of working with
here in the legislature and um uh and
while we're not employees we are a
Workforce and um uh and not only that
we're uh a group group of people that's
chosen to give up a lot of their free
time uh to serve here and um uh uh you
know the kind of things that pop up are
not are not things that uh people expect
and um
uh and
um and you know I felt like the the
group here kind of felt that yeah it
makes sense that under those types of
circumstances to have something
available the real issue is um uh is
we're not employees and it's called an
employee assistance program and
um and uh you know in in the strong need
for a bit of bit of Comedy last night
after you know pretty long day in here I
kind of wanted to think what could we
call it if it's not an employee
assistance program that applies to the
legislature and so I played around and I
came up with the name legislature urgent
resource crisis
hotline so it calls into the same
company same people same thing but we
just we just use the acronym lurch
so if you call it your cell phone would
come up with this picture and somebody
on the other end would say you
rang and um you know there's there's
outside groups that manage employee
assistance program there's no reason a
phone different phone number couldn't go
into the same place there's no reason
that the such a program couldn't be run
by the nurse give out give out a little
card um I mean I still I I think the the
amendment is fine but I I would
encourage um you know the house and the
and the government to make this kind of
service available uh for the the great
people who are who are compromising so
much I mean it's nice to that they
bought us a 100 pizzas last night uh and
uh huh they didn't who bought it your
people the party bought it huh the party
bought it well for you we were you you
didn't get pizza no no oh jeez no that
was well you know Ju Just because we're
not employees and uh and you're not an
employee doesn't mean that I think this
kind of service and support um uh would
be helpful so um I'm going to support
the amendment and uh and would would
would encourage that this kind of
service be available regardless of the
ultimate status of this
bill so to clarify uh when you said
comedy you you meant c m Ty Y and not
comedy
obviously right because you're sticking
to your day job I think but
uh okay so the to the extent that you
have anything serious with the Lurch
thing that's kind of funny
uh if this goes into effect in 27 then
then there could be a bill next year to
you know tweak it so that there might be
different phone numbers I I I don't know
that would I I don't I don't think you
mean to change this amendment today no I
don't mean to change the amendment all
right but I I I did want to say you know
sometimes semantics matter and there's
no there's no difference between
somebody calling up a phone number and
having it be an employee assistance
program or having it being the
legislature uh support Hotline Crisis
Hotline uh if they handle the calls the
same way but it may feel different to
some some of us who are voting on it and
uh and you know the incredibly ALU
altruistic purpose by which we come here
and serve we're not we're not here we're
not here to get some benefit that we
can't get somewhere else the this the
small thing that could still be out
there would be to in my view is um we we
heard that conflict resolution was among
the services and I think the conflict
resolution in between which parties
might need to be clarified I don't think
conflict resolutions between members of
the general court would be appropriate
you know if they're having conflict
issues with the neighbor or something
that's stressing them out that would be
fine but I so so actually I think if we
do accept this there would still be some
tweaks that would be needed next term
but um representative Wier
I still don't like the Optics of us
trying to get onto something that's an
employee program that was created for
employees we all have other ways of
supporting ourselves obviously because
we're not supported on what we get paid
here and we all have other other forms
of of income and and support so I think
that this this is not something and I
think that it much could be made of it
anybody that voted for it somebody that
was was running against you could say oh
you want everything the employees want
and you're only working so many hours
you know a lot some of our colleagues
work a lot fewer hours than we do and uh
you know it's so and some of them
deliberately do that and don't show up
much you'd be giving them a privilege
that they didn't earn much so I I don't
support
it representative H thank you Mr chair
um I do thank you um representative
torski for coming up with an amendment
to is at least constitutional per our US
Constitution Article
27 um I still have concerns and my
concerns stem from the number of
citizens in the town in my towns um that
don't have access to this they're
retired they're they work for themselves
whatever their life condition is that
puts them in a place that they don't
have access to an employee assistance
number um we do get calls we get calls
for all sorts of things as a State Rep
it sometimes is even relative to what's
going on in the town even though we're
not doing necessarily local politics if
there's a problem between a building in
inspector and and one of the citizens I
I get the phone
call and I want to make sure that we are
as close as possible to the people that
we serve um I think that's important so
if they don't have access to this level
of benefit um I don't know that I would
want to have it for us so with that I'm
going to be voting
no further comment uh representative
priest thank you Mr chairman I will be
voting uh in support of
HB uh
13 63 and the amendment that's been
offered uh today I think this is a very
valuable service for uh the general
court and for the amount of money that
is the cost of
it the services clearly
outweighs the cost of it and I think
it's something that all of the general
court can use uh and
I and that's I think it's important
thank
you further discussion I I I want to
break this into two two separate things
first we'll consider the amendment and
after we know what we want to do with
the amendment we'll talk about we'll
vote on the underlying Bill did you have
another
comment in response to the last comment
that was made I don't want anybody to
think that I don't see the value of
these of these Services I do think in
fact they're valuable um I don't know if
their approach is the correct one to
extend it from the employees that are
part of state government to the
legislature I think we need to figure
out whether we need a crisis hotline or
something else as a better solution I
mean last fall I got broadsided by
something I would never have expected
and spent the better part of six weeks
going through something with an
immediate family member that left me in
crisis um I spent several nights on the
cement floor at ham sorry at um Elliott
Hospital sitting next to somebody I
cared about or sleeping next to someone
I cared
about I understand that life some
sometimes throws us tough challenges and
we we do need a network but I don't
think in
my I even going through that personally
I don't think I can make the argument we
should extend this to to the members of
the general court and not figure out how
to do something similar or broader for
our
citizens any further
discussion app I appreciate the emotion
that you delivered that in a lot of
emotion for just this is just money come
on representative tki thank you I
appreciate everyone's Reflections on
this I just want to say that I think
that
um having support for our own well-being
and wellness makes us better better
legislators which allows us to serve our
constituents better and allows us to
provide a level of service to assist
them when they do reach out um in times
of Crisis and need and um I just think
it I just think it's the right thing to
do thank you thank you any further
comment okay so go ahead represent St uh
I guess I can make a motion to um uh
accept um Amendment
1257 uh onto HB 1363 is is there a
second seconded representative priest is
is every is everyone okay with the show
of hands on the
amendment okay so uh show a hands all
those in favor of accepting Amendment
224-1
1257 H raise your hand
okay those opposed raise your
hand did you vote okay did you get her
vote because I'm a big guy did you see
it six to three is what I had
yeah okay with with the the amendment
recommended for acceptance um is there
um I I assume the emot or the motion on
um 1363 is ought to pass uh we'll just
take that as motioned and seconded is
there is there anybody who motioned
pardon
me motion so yeah I I'd be happy to
motion um uh
1363 as amended by 1257 ought to pass
second second okay and then when you're
ready to take a recorded vote um we're
ready representative Leon
no representative Earth no
Representative hle no representative
wer representative walner yes
representative tersi yes representative
Stringham votes yes representative
priest
yes chairman Edwards
no okay so the vote uh being um uh four
Ys five Nays uh the motion uh ought to
pass uh
fails so we need an alternative
motion I'll move itl second seconded who
was the
second neor
I yell out next time well I heard
multiple yeses so
twice so uh the motion is itl
um uh before we vote is there any
discussion on the new
Amendment or excuse me the new motion
not seeing any we're ready for a vote
when you're ready yep
1257 uh representative Leon yes
representative F yes representative hle
yes representative
Wier uh Representative walner no
Representative tki no Stringham no
representative Priest No chairman
Edwards
yes the vote being five to four uh the
itl motion
passes so we're going to need somebody
to to write a blurb for and a blurb uh
against shouldn't we wait do we have a
blurb for the full finance and we we
will but the drafting process can begin
okay okay and and I just want to give
everyone an opportunity to use whatever
time they have available to write it
well I saw representative Wier the other
day uh when he was going uh in the full
finance committee he read the blurb as
part of his uh testimony money and that
seemed to be pretty slick because it he
one he got it done in time and two it
helped clarify what we were voting on so
um who who would who would be writing
the uh for the
itl h I'll do it that's the whole and
I'll do the Minority Report when we get
to that point Okay
so
but I'm going to hope for the best it'll
be it'll be the majority it's good to be
an
optimist um okay so on
1588 uh House Bill 158 Point order go
ahead I'm just curious are you skipping
1669 on purpose or did I miss something
no I I had changed the order on my sheet
of paper and it wasn't really clear to
you I I I'm it's it's next uh House Bill
uh 15
88 uh relative to court jurisdiction
over persons receiving special education
my note says we needed better numbers is
there anyone in the audience that are
here to present better
numbers how about you Mr Ripple did you
get any better numbers Mr White do you
have better numbers because we we didn't
we haven't this is one where we never
felt that we really had good numbers I
haven't received any updates
no
good afternoon members of the committee
Nathan white Chief Financial Officer of
the Department of Health and Human
Services and uh to clarify
representative Edwards when you're
better numbers this is on the on the
specific assumptions in the fiscal note
that the department used for the 32
count
correct right and then there was a lot
of testimony and and uh that seemed like
it was going to change or reduce those
estimates and what I think we asked was
just nothing official in a fiscal note
but um a clarification of what we think
the new order of magnitude would be
based on the discussions sure so we went
back and we looked at the original
methodology that we had used and um we
made an assumption that 3% of the total
population would be eligible and then we
recently pulled a live
sample oh she step out okay um we
recently pulled a an upto-date sample
that verified that there I believe there
were 32 individuals today in that age
group that would Age into the new
eligibility so our original assumptions
actually ended up turning out to be very
accurate so so you've uh reinds the
original fiscal note that attached to
1588 correct okay um representative
Earth ju just to clarify so
you confirmed it was between a little
under 2 million to six
million a year and going up from there
um we confirm the original census number
so the original census number was based
on a projection and so so the dollar
figures again are variable they're our
best estimate and the we provided a
range because it's ultimately very
dependent upon the service that that
individual needs
except I thought you said you looked at
these individuals
so you did you look at the particular
individuals or just the counts and then
you went to the worst and best cases we
we looked at we looked at the total
number of individuals we did not go Case
by casee and go down to the billing
level detail of each individual um
because when we're looking out to 26 and
27 those Services could change and then
in the long run those Services would
also be WI dependent and variable okay
so back to my question did you just so
is your range a worst case and a best
case is that the range yes okay so
there's no such thing as a
average in the world in this
world that's why we we didn't provide an
average because of because one it could
vary like five years down the road those
costs could be very different from two
years down the road that's why we did
not choose an average or a median okay
all right I maybe nice is to know that
you could have given us three values low
high and expected but
okay so so if we wanted to appropriate
Pro um you so that you uh you can run
your um the provide the services and run
the department should we put the worst
case in there or an average in terms of
of uh how much uh funding we need to
appropriate for this
bill
from a budgetary standpoint I would
always want more but I'm also very
respectful relative to The Limited funds
that everybody has um I think some
average would certainly be appreciated
ultimately at the end of the day we're
going to make sure that the services are
provided and so when we bring forward a
department-wide transfer to fiscal and
you see us moving around millions of
dollars it's to account for those
discrepancies that deviate from our
original
assumptions
the Mr Ripple this is as much to you as
anyone I I don't think we have an
amendment to 1588 it it seems to me that
if we pass it given that this is
supposed to go into effect in 60 days we
should probably include um an
appropriation what I think I've heard in
prior
testimony is that in effect the
Department's already doing this and and
and they're doing it out of their
existing budget but I think I've heard a
request from the Department to
supplement the funds that they've been
using does do you we don't have an
amendment you don't have an amendment to
do that I thought you had an amendment
to change the effective date but maybe
I'm thinking of another bill no there is
a there is there is an amendment
Amendment uh 1091 it says the the ACT
shall take effect July 1
2025 my notes say that regardless of
what the amendment says it's being
implemented now anyway so we were
wondering if that was right I I actually
ended up it's got my name on it doesn't
it I I think I I withdrew that after we
got testimony saying it we could we can
say whatever effective date we want but
the reality is that the Department's
already eaten this because it's in other
portions of our
law so so I'm thinking we may need a
supplement Al
appropriation what's your opinion I I
would certainly appreciate a
supplemental appropriation because we're
expanding the eligibility and and the
the obligation that that we would have
to uh address do do you have a
number in the fiscal note again we
provided a range right um we we can't
predict the future yeah I can't put a
range in an appropriation if if we'd
like to go right in the middle
um 3 million do I hear 3
million
yeah I I mean we'd be comfortable with
that all right so Mr Ripple could could
you work on an amendment it doesn't the
amendment would not change the 60 days
it would it would but it would put an
appropriation in there of 3 million and
that would go through the fiscal year
yes so for fiscal 25 a $3 million
appropriation I again I think I think
with OS working on a couple other
amendments um it might be unrealistic to
expect that back today but I think this
amendment would be simple enough that if
you wanted to vote on the bill with the
understanding that I would produce that
Amendment for later you could do that
and and then if it's not there then we
can clean it up in the full finance
committee correct right representative
wer
w i called wer I actually said a right
name
once so these people are supposedly now
on special ed
funds and likely 80% of that money is is
from the state special ed funds rather
than local
so any idea what the savings would
be because the these two programs aren't
equal in
costs I I'm I'm not understanding the
question savings where we'd be expanding
the population so next year we would
have additional costs that we wouldn't
have this
year
these these youths are now at at 21 so
they changed them at at from 21 to
22 the special ed thing took them
off after 21 right okay but the court
didn't so this is suggesting for the
court if I
recall okay so hopefully there would be
savings projected to what if they but I
guess they wouldn't have been paid out a
special ed anyway if that all we're
doing is aligning the court with what
the special ed did so they're not after
21 they're not covered by special at
anyway so all right so there is no
savings thank you worked it out
myself representative walner well this
is a small piece but when we were here
last there was um some testimony that
the case management would continue by
the schools is that is that
um I'm not that familiar with the
program I don't know if anybody come on
up good afternoon Rebecca Ross the
director of The Bureau for children's
Behavioral Health although the case
management would continue from the
schools for the purpose of the education
um DCF would still be obligated to
provide the same level of oversight for
the residential and Community parts of
the young adults life so dcyf would not
have any less obligation for these kids
as they do for any other um teenager or
young adult that they're serving thank
you representative Le on um thank you Mr
chairman I'm sorry if this is a dumb
question but the people who are
addressed by this what is happening
right now and who's paying for that
without this
bill I think in in some cases it's Case
by case but there's a disconnect because
the special leg goes through 21 where
the residential placement stops at 21
and so they're having to find individual
plans and transition plans for each
youth um which I think we heard the
testimony last week that includes some
of those cases individuals choosing to
end their special education services so
they can transition into the adult
system I I guess I was just trying to
figure out where the money is coming for
I I guess we've all trying to figure out
where the money's coming from previously
with the appropriation but maybe it's
more complex I think it's a lot more
complicated and individualized and I
think that in some cases certain things
just aren't happening because there
isn't money for them and in other cases
individuals that are supporting these
Youth and families are being really
creative to make sure they can meet most
of their needs but there is a
disconnect
Mr White the the 3 million and when I
said it I was thinking that's General
funds is there a federal match on
this this would be 100% General funds
100% General funds okay three three
million in any other
comments okay well thank you um
so so I would like to have a motion that
um on the amendment that I just
discussed with Mr Ripple that we would
not change the effective date that we
would supp add a supplemental
appropriation of $3 million for this
program and that that money would expire
and at the end of this budget cycle I
would say it should be
non-aps non- lapsing through this budget
cycle or through the after the end of
the cycle through through the through
the budget cycle that we're currently in
so it would be it excuse me I meant to
say lapsing I said the wrong I I I I got
dyslexic I want it I want it to lapse
yep so it lapse at the end of the bium
yes that's what I meant to say so so
thank you for tackling me um I was
running in the wrong
direction uh
representa tki
comment I like that idea of a motion and
I was going to offer to make the motion
so so you'll make a motion I'll second
okay so now what we'll do if we accept
this on a show of hands what we'll do is
Mr Ripple will put it in and we'll
verify that the amendment says what we
think it says prior to the next finance
committee meeting because that's the
next time we're scheduled to get
together is that acceptable to you Mr
chair okay um all right so go you have
further discussion uh yes discussion can
I ask one more
question so what will you be doing with
your budget in the next bium as it
relates to
this so part of this would depend on the
targets that that are set by the
governor's office and if the efficiency
expenditure Target is set at zero or if
we are allowed to include legislative
Appropriations from this prior year um
then that would ultimately determine how
this would come in the next budget but I
think there's there's could there's a
potential for a strong likelihood that
this may come through as a prioritized
need um being one of the most recent
elements coming in um where we would
include everything that's funded to date
as an efficiency expenditure um but
ultimately this would really depend on
what the revenues look like in the next
two months uh and the targets that were
given by the governor's
office and Mr Ripple is this one of
those um phrases where we need to
include it in the amendment that the
governor's authorized to draw a
warrant yeah we we'll include that for
any enal fund appropriation okay I
wanted to get that out there so that
when we see the actual Amendment no
one's surprised by that extra
Clause Mr representative wer for the
future budget we should have some idea
because we know the age groups we know
the age groups that going to be aging
out in the next budget and it we we
could take a look at the cases and get
some prediction likely to be the same or
a little less since most of the as we
look at the Agee cohorts in school it
seems like every age group going younger
gets smaller so there might be some way
to predict this for the next budget and
we'd be looking for that
thanks is there any further discussion
on the amendment as we've described it
it go ahead represent Stringham yeah I
just I just want to say you know we're
kind of handcuffed here this is
something we've already passed and um
you know we're looking at a program that
we're talking about $100,000 per
recipient per year to be in this and um
uh that that we're putting forward it
may cost double that it may cost half
that but the um
um you know I ideally I wish you know
that we and finance 3 had had this
discussion when the original bill was
passed even though I wasn't here then
but whoever happened to have my seat so
um uh I you know strongly recommend we
go forward I strongly think we should
put the money money forward to implement
what we have um as a as uh our states
Representatives have agreed to go
forward with
but but hopefully we'll have some
additional information I don't want to
put words in your mouth but it sound
like you said you're in favor of the
amendment all right
um if there is no other discuss
discussion uh I'll take a show of hands
of those that would be in favor of the
amendment as we described to Mr
Ripple okay that's looks
good and then with that I think we're
ready for another motion that's OT
related to
otpa representative priest thank you Mr
chairman I would U Move that we uh adopt
HB
5588 as
amended 1588 1588 I'm sorry thank
you is there a second seconded
representa
lurki when you're ready for a vote
represent
Stringham yeah the motion is uh a to
pass as amended by uh as of yet
on a motion is uh uh ought to pass on HB
1588 as uh amended or as will be amended
with a at this point unknown amendment
number um representative Leon
yes representative F no Representative
hle no representative
Wier representative walner
yes uh representative tki yes
representative Stringham votes yes
representative priest
yes and uh chairman Edwards yes the vote
being
7-2 um the motion
passes okay so will there be a minority
on this I I don't know wor I don't know
um you you got time if you want to write
an amendment representative Earth just
said he's not
okay or not an amendment but a blur blur
yeah no I understand um I just I'm
looking at the the lb's status of where
we are financially at this point and um
I'm just trying to figure out where
which bucket the money is coming from
because it's not real clear at this
point yes sir and and one of the things
I'm not sure if you were here or uh I
just didn't leave a a mark when I said
it I I had asked at the outset of the
hearings if division 3 had basically a a
budget or a ceiling that we should be
working within and the guidance I
received was uh my takeaway was let's go
through these bills do each one the
right way and then at the end of it
we'll pass the the recommendation to the
full finance committee and and we'll
have a better visibility on on the
availability of funds so when we get
when we get to the exact session we will
probably have some some figures from LBA
of what we've proposed and how much is
there including the education trust fund
the finance exact session yes yes sir
and and and just so division three knows
I I I hear that we we do have a big
spend in the education area that we're
anticipating I don't think so but but
there's 53 million over in division one
on that um r of of the from two% to 2
and a half% with group two
retirements okay that's going to be the
biggest
chunk represent a whole thank you a
question for um ultimately I think the
LBA is a whole can we get from you guys
an updated estimate by division of what
has been positively announced or agreed
to so far as recommendations and where
that puts us financially in terms of
Appropriations only yes yeah we can do
that thank you happened I saw something
all right
um is there anyone that wants to write
the affirmative blurb on
1588 1588 in
affirmative you you made the motion
representative Stringham who who did
representative priest did
okay okay
um let's go to House Bill
1669 I understand representative hle has
an an amendment for us to
consider I do Mr Ripple can hand it
out
um so during our discussion there was
the desire to make this um a
precautionary statement right prior to
entering into any relationship the
following shall be done but DHHS also
asked that they could get started on the
process to make this happen we had a
discussion about that and we needed to
allocate funds and a position to do that
um and this amendment does exactly that
this amendment authorizes a new position
and um allocates the funds necessary to
start the process to make sure that the
data um is Dean or
anonymized so so I'm going to I'm going
to ask us to spend the next minute
reading this and thinking about it and
then I'm going to go to representative
uh Leon who has been working this bill
the longest and hear what you
think
e
it it looks like everyone's right I
don't see any more lips moving
so so representative Leon what do you
think of this Amendment uh thank you Mr
chairman um I I like this amendment I
guess this is s of part of the problem
of people that are not in finance
writing bills and not realizing what the
consequences will be about um just
everything that we Implement uh the fact
that we have withdrawals from the
immunization information system is very
important and our state government
should be following all of our state
laws as they interact with other states
um the fact that this now allows us to
provide a position that's necessary in
order to stay consistent with all of our
state laws is quite important as is
appropriating that uh money for the
position and also for the it updates um
this is something that also is in the
process of going through and rulemaking
which makes this very important to make
sure that we have the position that will
allow the department to actually go
ahead and Implement what is already in
law and what is going in in rules as
well so this is um one of those great
opportunities to make sure that we're
actually going to continue to do what
our laws and rules say that we do and to
appropriate the funds um appropriately
and just going back to this whole
process with the IIs you know the
department did an amazing job getting
this up and running during covid um that
was a herculan job herculan task and
they did a great job making sure that it
was implemented so we could get all of
the vaccines that we needed to get um
when the state administered them so
thank you I I I have a fact question for
um Mr White and then I'll come to you
representative walner uh do you have a
copy of the amendment okay um I I just
need a an education and state Personnel
101 uh
lines 12 through
15 uh lays out the scope of
responsibilities for this new position
what I'm concerned about is um I I I I
don't want to create a situation where
this person
only does what's in the scope of what's
written here and if time was available
would not believe that they needed to do
other tasks as assigned so is this is
this a a hard limitation on the scope of
duties or is this just sort of the
initial um uh job description kind of
thing but they would still be expected
to do more as time is available
so a in in every probably almost every
sjd that I've seen there are
accountabilities and one of the
accountabilities at the bottom and other
tasks as a sign B I wouldn't necessarily
interpret this language to be
restrictive that this is the only thing
that they could work on so I would not
anticipate that typically you would only
see that with very finite federal grants
that have very specific requirements um
I I will let the expert here though
speak to the other duties that the
position would perform hello um in Mary
mcer from the immunization section thank
you very much um for your question what
we would do is essentially we have
similar types of positions so we would
look at the the uh degree and the amount
of effort that was put towards this
particular initiative and it's most
likely that we would have an individual
time allocated um so that if these funds
these State Appropriations were made um
um we would make sure that there would
be some accounting and adjustment of you
know how much level of effort was needed
for this particular initiative um
currently you know we do have uh quite a
bit of withdrawals that are coming into
the department so at this point in time
it would be a big gu but we don't know
what the withdrawal numbers would be in
the future or once this effort was um in
play and really streamlined we want to
make sure that we have that ability to
um you know properly fund this position
with the appropriate dollars um
depending on what the accountability of
this Duty would be Eads that sounds far
more complex than what I was hoping the
reality would be I I what I was hoping
is that we'd give you some money for the
position that you'd go fill the position
and then at that point we we didn't
create a big bookkeeping thing where you
had to make sure that there was an audit
Trail between that money in that person
are you telling me there really is that
level of a a bookkeeping re ired to
maintain that kind of an audit Trail um
most likely yes because um when we do
look at the level of effort from
positions we do tend to do some time
allocations depending on the funding
source so you know I like efficiency if
you could tell me something about how we
do this in an efficient way Mr White
that would be
great I I I I believe the the the
question that you were trying to get at
is is this person going to sit around
and do nothing if all of these Duties
are assigned and the answer would be no
and I don't know if you can give
examples of like the other type of
functions they may
perform sure so we have approximately uh
450 providers that actually use the nhas
system I I think I'm going to accept no
okay thank and and then because we we
got to get out of here so so thank you
very much representative Wen did you
have a question
did it's really for Mr White if um so
there is um in the amendment
$80,000 for the uh onetime enhancement
to the New Hampshire immunization
information system and when I go to my
fiscal note which I have do have a note
here at one point we were anticipating a
$3 million cost that's an
incredible an incredible amount of
difference there can you do it for
80 do do you have an answer to that this
this is a weers number though isn't it I
I I believe there were changes via an
amendment and I believe representative
Lon was going to speak to that
representative Leon uh thank you there
was a whole another task that had been
in the bill initially um but that was
amended out in Health and Human Services
I believe there's an updated Financial
note um it's we just don't have the
printed out copy with with us but this
88 80,000 I believe is consistent with
the updated
note great questions so any other
discussion on this uh representative did
I hear one over here
no okay so I'm not hearing any more
discussion on the whole Amendment uh
1274 I move we adopt 1274 each is there
a second second second all right um I'll
accept a show hands of all those in
favor of adopting
1274 okay those
opposed okay so so so N9 nothing not
81 I just said do
it okay so we need a
opa oh otpa the other way um a motion so
moved second and second okay so we're
ready for a vote when you are Mr
secretary motion is ought to pass on HB
1669 as amended by Amendment 1274
h
representative Leon yes representative
Earth yes representative hle yes
representative Wier yes representative
walner yes representative tersi yes
representative Stringham votes yes
representative priest yes chairman
Edwards yes nine
nothing all right uh thank you let's go
to
1598 status check have you have you
gotten amendments on 1573 I have not
okay would it be worth pinging them or
is it better just to leave them
alone um I did mention that you wanted
them this afternoon and you planned on
um you planned on taking all votes by
245 so they know that but I'm not sure
if the Amendments will be ready by that
time all right thank you all right so
we'll go to House Bill 1598 I understand
there's an amendment that representative
walner is
offering
give everyone a moment to read
it
have you seen it already represent wner
okay and then when you're ready you can
speak to your
Amendment everybody every guys
readit so last week we had an amendment
H um which would
have really actually done two things it
would have provided um the department
with a
position and it would have provided um a
consultant to work with the Department
around the preparation of a report and
um
information on how to implement and
manage the Social Security
payments there seem to have been um some
questions about the um position so what
I am bringing forth today is an
amendment I do have others that you can
choose from too but this is the one I'm
going to bring forth
first this what this position what this
uh Amendment does is um just provide for
a consultant that would work with the
Department um around um the uh
management of the Social Security
payments and the implementation of um
these this program and um the report
would be due by December
31st so yes it would not be available
for inclusion
in the a Governor's budget proposal but
it would be available to the house when
the budget came to us to take a look at
it um at that point and um I did put
that the um consultant that was hired
would need to be knowledgeable in um the
efforts that are taking place in other
states and there are a number of states
who are moving forward with this
um
proposal so I'll come to you in just a
second I I I I I think it's I think it's
fair to uh point out that representative
wer and I I talked about this the other
day and and this is this is an approach
that uh she and I uh agreed to
tentatively I wanted to see what the
amendment said actually How It Was
Written um but I I um my my my thought
on this was that um we had such
diametrically opposed points of views on
this bill that this was really an a
relatively simple no new Manpower kind
of program to implement to the
department I think saying something that
they wanted on the order of magnitude to
about 10 people and there was a lot of
you know liability that was associated
with this maybe that was my paranoia but
um but in any case with such a
diametrically opposed uh set of
viewpoints um the obvious thing for the
legislature to do in that situation
would be direct interim study and I I
didn't want to just direct interim study
I I wanted this fully vetted and and so
that's that's that's why I was happy to
agree with representative walner that we
should go get a consultant but not just
any consultant we wanted to get a
consultant who actually could tell us
something we didn't already know that's
why that last sentence on 13 through 15
in the first section is important so um
so that that's what I have to say about
that representative
hle thank you Mr chair so the member
from conquer right if I recall and I
spoke afterward and I'm in agreement
with the concept of trying to get the
information we need we need to make an
informed decision
um my only concern and I expressed this
earlier privately was $200,000 is a lot
for a 9month contract this is going to
be done by the end of the year I've been
in a Consulting business for quite some
time um you could hire a very competent
person for a very long time at that rate
I'm okay with this idea I think the
number is higher than we would I would
love to see that number reduced to
$100,000 I think finding somebody for
$100,000 to get a report by the end of
the year is very reasonable consider ing
what we're asking him to
do represent walner so I uh the $200,000
wasn't something that I personally
thought up it was um from an amendment
that the department had provided to me
as a suggestion for how to move forward
on this bill so the $200,000 was
something the department did suggest to
me so they might be able to tell you um
why that number was was picked and um
whether they think they could actually
find someone to do this kind of work at
a lesser
amount is it possible we ask the
department for that I just at a at a
$200 an hour that's still a th000 hours
it's a lot right and a $200 an hour
consultant is a highly paid consultant
um I know of Professional Engineers and
others who aren't making quite that much
so
I think there's there's not even 2,000
hours worth of time between now and
December at any reasonable level I I do
think this can be done for Less I think
we should ask the department to see to
figure out how to do that for less and
if we make that the amendment I will
gladly put my name on this at at the
lower dollar value I I'm not arguing the
dollar value I'm I'm arguing um the the
content of what the 200,000 may may end
up buying because we want somebody who
actually knows something about other
states it could be somebody who lives in
another state and has Transportation
costs and has to stay here to interview
people here no so Mr White do you want
to speak to the the sanity of the
200,000 sure um it is not very well let
me back up I think one important thing
is we're not just is paying for report
we'd also be paying to have technical
assistance come during the house phase
potentially during the Senate phase and
after so the terms of the contract the
contract wouldn't just end on December
31st we'd likely want the report and
then it be have the opportunity for
follow-up work during the budget process
because I'm assuming the report would
only elicit more questions which may
elicit more questions um so when we were
thinking about this we were looking at
some of the uh hourly rates that we do
pay uh some of the technical providers
um or or Consultants that that we have
which are sometimes in excess of 100
$200 $300 depending upon the nature and
service of the work um ultimately this
would be a soul Source contract so we
would not be following this to in order
to reach the deadline so we would not be
going through a competitive bid process
through those negotiations we could
potentially get that down again this is
our best guest ballp perk conservative
we're always going to be you know more
on the conservative side because I don't
want to run out of money um but if if if
if if there's some reduction to that we
can try to do the best job that we can
to make it work um but this was a
solution that we had proposed to try to
find some path forward so so two points
so do do we need uh simple one do we
need to write not to exceed 200,000 or
is it not to exceed understood that's
implicit in the authority okay and then
the second one uh is uh I liked what you
said about having this individual around
to help us with any potential
implementation I I like hearing that but
I'm not seeing it in the write up I'm
seeing that the report shall have the
purposes of blah blah blah around 11 and
12 um somewhere in there I I I I read
that the report would have some
implementation guidance I'm not reading
that the consultant would have
implementation responsibilities is is
this wording accurate um I mean we could
have a simple sentence saying the
consultant shall provide technical
support throughout the ter throughout
the duration of the contract the
duration of the contract will be
extended through June 30th
2025 at minimum something like that see
I I like that additional language
because I thought that's what we
represent Wallner I think that's what
you and I were talking about on the
phone we wanted somebody around to help
us with the implementation
so
um okay so representative hold is this
with that the fact that we want the
person
longer the in the tail end of the
implementation does that change your
point of view I I'm still in support of
the idea right again um having been a
professional consultant for a while I
just the dollar value that is
effectively getting someone more than
half time for an entire year which which
is is a significant size contract if you
if we find the right person who has this
expertise whether they've done the work
in California or Alaska doesn't matter
where they can most of this can be done
remotely they might have to come out
here for some travel um but really this
is creating a report and then being
available as a consultant to answer
questions for um the next budget
creation I still think the number's High
personally
but that's where I'm
at
any other comments representative
walner
well I would like to see I would like to
see this happen and um I think that Mr
White we we know Mr white pretty well at
this point I think he'll be very careful
when he is choosing a uh consultant and
he
will be doing it for probably the best
buy he can find and trying to be very
conservative with the money so I trust
that they know what they are going to
need in order to
get the right person to bid on this and
to do this work so um I'm hoping that we
can leave it at the
200,000 um and let the department try to
manage that so so Mr White Mr Ripple uh
L on line 16 that that Roman numeral 2
section do we have to say anything or
should we say anything about lapsing or
non-aps it's assumed that it would lapse
at the end of the banum if it it doesn't
say otherwise but if we want this
individual to help us with
implementation we may actually not be
implementing until a subsequent
year um well I think you'd be
implementing through the budget process
that takes place in 2025 no so I'm not
sure you would need it beyond June 30th
of 2025 there's a provision in RSA 9
that dollars are encumbered in a
contract those dollars can be carried
forward into the next biennium in RSA 9
there's also inherent language that all
General funds would lapse at the end of
the year unless otherwise specified okay
so then the only thing I'm hearing then
that this amendment could uh be improved
through a tweak is to make it more clear
that this consultant has
responsibilities during the
implementation phase and not just the
report can yeah go ahead Mr Ripple how
how about something as simple as on line
13 to assist in the preparation of this
report comma and to assist the
department with the implementation of
the report's recommendations comma the
department shall I I I I'm okay that
feels like it does it uh representative
B that's fine but when you're done I
have a question oh okay represent hle
sure can we also put in that line in the
in the recommendations relative to the
creation of the budget for the fiscal
year ending
2027 right I think this is about
creating the budget items at next spring
so I think that's the element that's
important right I'm sorry which what did
you want to add what you what did you
want to change there line 13 to assist
in the preparation of this report and
then you added something and then I
would add also right in in the
preparation of the budget ending for the
2027 fiscal year okay
sure further comment on this amendment
representative wer I
hello I'm sorry I I see my boss raise
his hand it just it's the shiny object
you I I'll get right back to
you uh how common is it for these foster
children to be having these Federal
benefits is this fairly common
it it seems to me it might not be that
that
common so part
the I I don't have my notes in front of
me but the fiscal analysis where we came
up with the estimate for $2 million of
general fund impact um that that that's
the the Lost Revenue that we would
experience off the top of my head I
believe 1.4 million of that would be for
individuals that we're currently
claiming tanif funds for that we would
subsequently be uh claiming SSI for and
then the in the other case it would be
the s SSI dollars that we're currently
applying towards their services that we
would no longer be able to so we would
have that additional general fund I
don't have the exact population um
figures in front of me I can go back to
them I think more in terms of numbers
like dollar numbers um when I'm thinking
about this so I I
apologize representative Earth thank you
Mr chair this is a question for Mr
Ripple is there any reason that we
couldn't appropriate maybe maybe the
wrong word but appropriate the money
from their laps from the Department's
laps are are you suggesting we just
would authorize them to have a smaller
lapse than what we already prescribed
MH um so I think in that case you
wouldn't necessarily you wouldn't need
an appropriation at all um because it
would come from their existing budget
and it's money that they wouldn't
lapse so I would try to go that route
and
I haven't thought about it for a moment
so my first reaction is does does that
make it more complicated and and and if
is there value in making it more
complicated it's the same amount of
dollars net anyways isn't it why why
would is why would the net change
because you are appropriating $200,000
here which will go to them won't lapse
whereas if you just take it out of what
they already spent just will be whatever
they need to spend up to the
$200,000 but my question about the net
though is if you say that you can just
give us a smaller lapse
number uh then then that's the money
that smaller laps the Delta of the
smaller laps number is the same as what
we're adding so is there really a change
well ask Mr Ripple but I my understand
lapses and Appropriations are
different they are different um but I
think if the assumption is the
Department's going to spend $200,000 on
this study that's a $200,000 cost either
way it's either $200,000 that they don't
lapse or it's $200,000 more that you
give them um I
think potentially the impact
of not including an appropriation and
staying silent on the the dollar amount
is
that
you know I'm going to leave that thought
leave that thought oh that was
intriguing go ahead see if you can see
if you can conclude that that's a that's
interesting where you're going I think
as written you're directing the
department to spend a certain dollar
amount whereas if you contain if you
include no appropriation um they'll
contract for whatever amount they
contract for um that could be less than
200,000 it could be I don't want to say
the Department's incentivized to spend
as little as possible but that that
would be the incentive right right and
and then and then what would we do with
lapse language anything like reducing
the laps or I think you would include no
Lang no language if you were inclined to
go that route you wouldn't need an
appropriation you wouldn't need any
non-aps language you would just put
nothing in there about dollars so Mr
White shows up the fiscal committee
saying he's broke and he doesn't have
any more money to do anything is is it
kind of our fault if we don't if we're
creating a new task and we're not
putting new money are we really doing
our job let follow go go go ahead oh Mr
White since you've been in this
position do you recall what the amounts
you were expected to lapse and how often
you made those
amounts yes so in in the past we
certainly have laps dollars I I I just
want to add a couple of points of
clarification um number one the laps
isn't in chapter 106 nor is it in
chapter 79 the lapse is assumption
included in the Surplus statement that's
not part of state law the laps is the
assumption that we use to balance the
budget so the I think this year it's
assumed 79 million laps I don't know if
that comes out to about 4% or so um we
do have a back of the budget cut which
is the $23.4 million which is the money
that it we are required obviously the
state budget is dependent upon the laps
and that's how we balance things um yes
we would basically what would happen is
we would come back
and we would probably have a smaller
lapse based upon whatever this cost I
think the Challenge from my perspective
and this is not my role sitting in the
executive branch this is a legislative
branch policy decision is whether you
pass appropriate whether you pass
requirements that you know are going to
have a cost but do not apply an
appropriation towards that I think
that's where get a little less
transparent from a budgeting perspective
because what we'll have to do is we will
have to come through goal probably to
move funds into a Contracting 102 or 103
line so you will see that at that point
in time but it will not be shown in the
legislation here but there will be a
trail I think it's interesting
that it's as much as 79 million and it's
4% I think that's something we could
keep in mind that you know that's an
expectation and I have have you made it
before the ex within the
expectation yes yes the first year of
the bium is typically smaller currently
we are projecting a very small lapse the
previous bium the previous bium we did
lapse um did you make the 4% yes at the
end of the bium that's what I remembered
is you were better at this than some of
your predecessors so correct thank you
so represent Stringham and then
hold you know the way the way I see this
exercise and not just talking about this
one bill but um we're uh in this second
year of the banum passing new uh uh
requirements for
expenditure and uh they're going to come
from a lot of different directions three
different Finance committees and at some
point we're going to decide which ones
we can afford to do hopefully all of
them but if there's too much money being
spent and we can't do them all
apparently there'll be another process
to prioritize things and if we just take
one bill here and say well this one has
no cost they're just going to say okay
we'll put that one through that has no
cost and if we do that for a lot a lot
of these different bills as we've done
is heaped on uh uh uh Mr White is a lot
of EX a lot of requirements with no
money because when we go through the
prioritization
exercise um these bills will have been
on different footing so uh if 200,000 is
a reasonable number for what we want to
do and um I would prefer that we
actually appropriate it at this and and
put it in the amendment at this this
time for this bill uh and and uh being
the appropriate exercise for everything
else that follows this person
whole thank you and maybe either Mr
White or Mr Ripple will know the answer
if we were to up update the laps the 23
something million that was requested in
the budget in hb2 could that be modified
down by the
$200,000 and captured in an amendment
here well the laps assumption is not
contained in state law any anywhere it's
in the uh Surplus statement prepared by
the LBA only so no Amendment would be
necessary this was the back of the
budget cut that was 23.4 Million I
thought was in H too I see the I'm sorry
the lapse is an assumption in the
Surplus statement only the back of the
budget cut yes that's in uh the back of
house bill one so that could be modified
by the $200,000 if you were inclined to
go that route is there a way to do that
in an
amendment yep it could
be this amendment could be redrafted to
also amend House Bill one from last
session I I would be in favor of that
all right representative tersi sorry I
apologize I'm over here
I think we have just gone down a
complicated rabbit hole that is entirely
unnecessary I mean we started with a
fiscal note that I think we all said
this is
concerning representative walner did
some work did some creative thinking
figured out a way that we can start the
process to address this issue of
children in our care that are receiving
Social Security
payments um I personally would have
liked to have gone further with the
original Bill however I think that the
proposal that was drafted here by hiring
the consultant is a wonderful first step
that we will be able to have the
information and the data and specifics
on where we need to go with our next
budget I 100% agree we should not be
passing things and just hoping that
there's change in the bottom of the
pocket that are going to be able to pay
for it I think that just sets a
dangerous precedent and um it's like
we're just passing things wishing and
hoping that things get budgeted for and
I hope that we can agree that the
language that we had to um have the
consultant work through the budget
process I think that was an excellent
suggestion um I'm happy to hear that the
intention is to have them available to
guide us through the budget process with
the report and I hope that we can um go
ahead and support the
amendment
representative so while I respect your
point of view and I don't really
disagree with it except for the
following the precedent I see a setting
is the base we're putting at Consultants
fees this is an incredibly High base
I've been in the software business for
40 years and I'm a fairly well-paid
consultant I've never this is a $400,000
per year rate which is pretty stiff the
only thing I was trying to do was to get
to the point of let them spend the money
that they need to do what you're asking
to do I agree this is
fantastic but to set the precedent that
we should
be laying down rates like this is a I
think that's a bad president quite
honestly uh
I think my concern is about the total
value Echo um representative Earth's
concerns um and I come at that from
being in also being a consultant in in a
wellp feel I guess if we take it as a as
a change to to the mandated laps in hb2
the department is really going to be
optimizing their costs potentially
differently than if we just allocate the
money because at the end of the day
they're still going to have to manage
trying to hit that laps request that's
in
hb1 and they can juggle the cost of this
consultant versus the other things that
they have to get done priority wise
which is slightly different in terms of
an implementation and and that's my
opinion but I think we do incentivize
them to optimize that number and I was
asking for a lower number I'm okay with
the change of the $200,000 but if we do
it via changing the hb1 laps value I
think we're better
off representative Leon um thank you Mr
chairman I I think what I'm hearing from
this is we all agree that this is an
important job we just have a question
about how best to do it and what
anchoring points we're setting um the
points that have been made over here are
why um I probably I guess I'll vote
against it because I think a back of I
think this other one where we're not
anchoring to the $200,000 I like that
point of not anchoring the cost of the
contract but I think that this is really
good work and I expect it'll probably
pass this committee it's just an idea of
setting that cost of the contract at
$200,000 I'm still new um it's just part
of my confusion within this whole
process but I think that those are
really good points that have been
raised so the precedent that I would
hope that we would stick to that's been
established in the past hopefully is
that if we legally require the
department to do new work incremental
new work work then we should put the
incremental dollars necessary for them
to do that work uh if we say you do this
work if you have the money and you can
prioritize it then that changes our
recommendation we're no longer telling
them to do it we're telling them to
think about it and so I I believe what
we've a what we want in this amendment
is we want to direct them to do it if
we're going to direct them to do it it
seems to me that we have the obligation
to fund the new work whether the dollar
amount is right is a different thing I
you know if you want to make it 150 or
something and and let the department
figure out if it turns out to be more
than that I'm I'm good with that I just
like the principle of you must do new
work here are the resources to to get it
done uh representative priest thank you
Mr chairman um again I guess there's a
lot of Consultants or previous
Consultants around this table because I
was also one in one time and I and I
really believe yeah and I and I believe
that the
20,000 is a very um realistic number and
we've heard from the Department that it
will be up to two 200,000 and so if they
can get a con consultant less I think
they will do that and it's just not
writing a report it's the actual
implementation of it with the department
and that is very time consuming so I
think this amendment makes sense and I
think uh I would like to make a motion
that we approve Amendment 1286
H after we make the
trats can I ask clarification on that
though we we we had a sidebar with Mr
Ripple about about modifying the
language to make it more clear that we
want this consultant to continue in the
post report phase to help us in the
implementation phase so so so we're not
is your motion is not literally to
approve
1286 your motion as I understand it is
to approve 28
1286 with the additional language
regarding being available in the
impementation correct correct correct
yes I was assuming that that was in
they just want to be clear so that
people know what they're voting on
exactly okay and then your second covers
that oh I'm sorry so yeah second
okay okay um so so with that um you've
made a motion is there any further
discussion on the on the motion
representative string uh I also am a
consultant so because I joined the group
I'm a recovering consultant by the
way so this is what happens when when we
don't get new Consulting gigs I guess
and so so you know these kind of
projects in in the types of firms I've
work and they're done by five and six
people not by not by one person with a
special expertise in there and um but um
uh you know I F first of all I I think
taking the the money out of the back of
the envelope is just a little too cute
for the process I'd much prefer to
appropriate it um I would support this
amendment I'd also support if it was
$150,000 I think that's probably a
pretty solid amount of money for
everything that's in in in the group um
uh but um so that that's just kind of
where I am so represented priest would
you be open in modifying your amendment
to make it 150,000 instead of 200,000
okay all
right any further
conversation all right so I'll I'll take
a show of hands uh all those in favor of
1286 is verbally modified please raise
your
hand for the amendment the amendment
right 1286 is the amendment
number right okay so so I think that was
90 any any oh it wasn't any well I'll
find out any
opposed okay so 91 or 81 rather
um okay so now we need uh an
o o yeah
otpa any
motion
I'm not seeing a motion you're going a
motion I will motion ought to pass as
amended for House Bill 1598 with the
previously approved verbal Amendment
with the specified language to be
drafted all right is there a second
second I second
it okay so when you're
ready yes Mr chairman the motion is for
House Bill 1588 ought to pass as amended
by yet unnumbered Amendment
representative Leon yes representative F
no Representative hle no representative
wer representative walner yes
representative tersi yes Stringham votes
yes representative priest yes chairman
Edwards
yes by the never ever heard before final
tally of 7-2 the motion
passes okay did now in passing
representative wner you mentioned that
you had a variety of amendments we could
choose from I I are you going to offer
any of them okay thank you oh God okay
so it is 150 we have one more thing on
our chart and that is house bill
1573 you want to give us
uh yeah we did 1282 yes sir that was
amongst the three that I verified at the
very beginning that our Monday
recommendation of O otpa stood and
nobody challenged it do you do you wish
to challenge the OT I see it on my notes
9 to zero okay okay all right
1593 1593 was also an otpa that we did
Monday so I just received those two
amendments and sent them to the printer
so in a few minutes I should have those
two okay so let's do this I I want to
see the real Amendment if we can
wherever we can um so let's take a
recess for uh I
have 1:1 we'll take a recess till 2 2
p.m 9
minutes
e
going here in a
moment
I I I should have noticed noted famous
birthdays today Lila that inspired Eric
Clapton's song turns 80 today and
William Shatner turns
[Music]
yeah so I'm running out of things to say
until representative comes
back well the first things I want to say
I think he needs to hear
though
I'm so cold up there in the second bro
too I was glad I was wearing my uh
blanket it's uh it's really a cake but
it feels like I call it by
blanket because it's an expensive
blanket Ralph flid sells
it um it's a casm wool BL so it does an
it and it keeps me pretty
warm
all right I think we're all back and uh
I'm going to call us out a recess we're
here to talk about House Bill
1573 uh we've talked about this several
work sessions and and so um I I think uh
um folks who've been following along
realize that uh
just m Miss Morris would you would you
sit up at the
table because I I'm going to go through
the amendments to the Amendments uh and
I I just need you to make sure I I don't
misstate um okay so we we've been going
through this uh Miss Morris
Miss Lisa I'm so sorry I'm going to put
your
name m Lissa Lissa
machete no yeah yeah I'm going to need a
business card for I will never get it
right until I like look at your business
card uh and and then uh Elizabeth KGAN
from right did I say it right she's
Aaron Aaron oh okay I I like I like
Elizabeth too if you want to change her
name at this point but um the the the
three of them and others have just been
working really really hard on this and
um and for those who worry about Finance
getting into policy I I will rationalize
my behavior uh whenever I do this by
thinking that it's a part of our
fiducial responsibility our fiduciary
responsibility to make sure that that uh
we uh get the cost structure of any bill
down to where it's a sustainable and
effective bill that and I know people
disagree with that but but I I that's
what I think uh part of our Charter is
and so we've been working on the policy
side a lot on
1573 thinking that
by making agreements uh on the policy
side of this
bill that we would continue to protect
children that we would meet the
expectations that that we have of
ourselves and that the OCA is here to
help remind us of and and that we would
do it in a way in which the program was
going to be uh inherently more
sustainable than the way that the policy
was initially
proposed and I I think I haven't looked
at the numbers but I I think we did
reduce the overall initial fiscal note
by what we've done if you if you flip to
like Pages
um six of the big Amendment which is
labeled
1290 um you'll I think you'll start to
see and and maybe it's for the first
time the the the impact the headcount
impact where on lines 32 to 33 we've got
four FTE there on the next page on line
six and seven we have 10 FTE on line 15
of that page we' got one more FTE so if
I I may be missing some FTE but but
that's at least
15 that's a bunch of people for for this
program now um I will say that what
happened in Tennessee was horrible I
will say that the people in Tennessee
failed to to do their duty to live up to
what we thought their obligations were
and that we probably failed to do the
proper compliance verifications and it
was a bad bad
thing I think that it's my perception
that this bill is largely intended to uh
address that that gross error um in a
way in which
I I it it has felt to me from the outset
that that this bill is over engineering
a solution it's putting too much into
statute that really ought to be
something that goes into the rules or
goes into departmental
policy um and I and I and I think this I
think this uh uh proposal has always
been just too thick with things that
belonged in policy and and as an example
of that I
offer um where it talked about a safe
place and how it was important that the
the the child and the uh and the casew
worker find a safe place to talk about
okay I think that's really great from a
a a therapeutic uh perspective and uh
but I don't think that needs to be in
law this is just an example of where
we're putting too much to the law that
should really be living um in in policy
that's just an example so so I I'm I'm
going to uh offer up
1290 as um respect for all the work
that's been done and to transfer the
amendment process from representative
Pearson to somebody on division three I
think that's proper protocol or in the
into Finance at least and I and in this
I made a couple of small tweaks and and
this is where I'm going to ask for your
help um Miss Morris somewhere I don't I
the Line is now gone so I don't know
where it was but there was a line that
said we shall not consider a a lack of
availability or resources in our
decision making and that that always
confounded me so so where where in
1290 would that ghostline language B if
we hadn't eradicated
it um there are multiple places but
first one is on page one line
19 where it says a lack of foster family
homes or Community Based resources shall
not be it now says shall not be an
acceptable primary reason for placement
in a residential facility so you fixed
it by inserting primary correct all
right I I I I can live with that okay
okay and then there were two other
places where it echoed
that that's all right I I think you I
think you cleaned it up um and then
we're going through it with you at the
same time so okay what and then what was
what was the second thing did it seemed
like I had two or three things that we
tweaked in
here one was a discussion about the
twice per year visits one which
unannounced you just kind of wanted that
reworded so that it didn't I didn't want
to change your agreement I just wanted
it clean what what what line is that you
know that is
now page three starting on line
okay okay so so what we what what I did
in this amendment was um we're at the
end of 25 where it says that these
visits at least twice per year of which
at least one shall be announced
previously instead of the words of which
it said including and I I just thought
the saying of which was more precise in
terms of what we were trying to do it
doesn't change the number or the thought
it just makes it easier for somebody
who's never read this before to read it
and understand it was was there a third
one yes it was regarding um the 5 days
provision um so if you look at page six
starting on line one as long as a child
remains in a residential treatment
program the department shall submit
evidence to the court and all parties at
least five and you wanted to clarify
whether that was calendar or business
days right and you've clarified it as
business and that and that's what you
all as you negotiated it had in mind
that it was always intended to be five
business days and notal I clarified that
with I believe that's already in the
court rules which is why we hadn't said
business specifically but I believe it
is business days under the current just
okay I I we're writing new law so I just
wanted to get it right okay so that was
not trying to change policy that was
just trying to add clarification I think
that was it or was there a fourth there
was one more I'm trying to find where it
is
now it's regarding
the safe place determined by a case
worker
um because I wanted it clear that only
one person can make a
decision it's page two line
25 page
[Music]
225 it shall include a private meeting
with the child in a safe place is
determined by the casew worker the
previous itations of this said something
to the effect that it should be a safe
place as determined by the child and the
casew worker and I'm just an old
military guy and somebody has to be
clear on who has the decision-making
Authority now this is also my example of
what should not be in law this is way
too detailed this should be in a and it
already is I was told in a previous
meeting that the safe place language was
already in policy somewhere and then we
were bringing it into the law for some
reason and it's just too much so so I'm
going to I'm going to be offering 129 is
that it are th are those all the changes
from basically the Pearson Amendment
Miss
Morris and then obviously the CH big
changes are the money we didn't have all
the money we didn't have the
Appropriations but we we have that
now yes and then on page three starting
on oh not starting on line 32 but at
line 32 um this discusses the annual
recertification if a facility has been
recertified or certified and then a
child is removed and then another child
isn't placed for at least 120 days after
that child was the other child left um
we would do another in-person
certification visit to since we have not
had eyes on that facility in any
capacity in the past 120 days all right
okay so I I think that drove us through
this amendment and and we'll come back
and we'll discuss it but I wanted to do
a compare and contrast with what I I
decided ad hoc after talking to Ms
Morris this morning about sort of the
final final changes uh to the amendment
and and so
1291 is is
um my attempt to say um that that this
policy is not necessarily done the
department has already taken a lot of
steps towards implementing changes in
their policy they've already begun to
behave differently they have new
management focus on this the likelihood
of having a similar problem has been
vastly reduced I believe based on the
attention that's been paid on this and
and so much of what is in the amendment
1290 I think is already finding its way
into policies without a law um so so
rather than us getting into the Weeds on
the law what I what I proposed
instead is
um with the with maintaining
the the statement and purpose and the
findings to make sure that we all know
what we're talking about I I I simply
said that we would
appropriate uh a million dollars between
now and the end of the the budget cycle
which is June 30th
2025 so that they have the additional
resources to do the additional work that
that they've already said that they
would do in policy and a million
well I put it on line six I put a
million it's it's the small amendment
that I'm sorry I made a transition to
1291 and and I'm I'm I'm I support 1291
as where I'm going with this because I I
wanted to get the legislature out of the
weeds but I wanted to make sure that the
department continued to have the
resources to to implement the Improv mov
ments and the
change and and I and I'm confident in
the department to do that um but they
you know they're going to need resources
because they do intend to to travel more
frequently um and spend more money on uh
the documentation necessary for the
courts to adjudicate each case properly
so so so they've already accepted more
workload this million dollars is um is
is is a commitment from the legislature
to say recognizing that there's new work
that flowed out of the failures in
Tennessee that it's trying to be
addressed by the department and and and
here some resources that are intended to
facilitate those improvements that
that's what I'm trying to say with
1291 and and
so with with that I'm I'm offering them
both up for discussion kind of
simultaneously so that people can ask
questions of what I what what the heck I
thought I was doing here so
representative
hle thank you Mr chairman thank you for
your work in this on page four of
amendment
11909 um line seven there's ran numeral
six that talks about any placement of a
child outside New England shall require
the approval of the dcyf director prior
to placement I don't see that copied
forward in 1291 am I missing it no I I
don't think you're missing it um no that
was not copied but but that but that to
me can be done in policy they they they
can set that up without it being in law
so so what I wanted to do was to make
sure that with
1291 that I Advanced a Germaine
Amendment
you know because it's clearly within the
scope of what we've been talking about
but I didn't want to replicate all of
the policy decisions that that are in
1290 yes sir I I believe this that one
section might be valuable in statute and
the reason I say that is it directly
impacts the families whose children are
in these centers and their ability to
travel to see them routinely so there's
a big difference between a road trip to
Maine or to Massachusetts or Vermont or
even I don't know Connecticut versus um
Tennessee and I personally I would argue
that that Roman numeral that sub small
subsection would be something that would
be line S through nine yes
sir I I I don't I don't see a problem
with that other than opening the
temptation to put everything back into
1291 which which sort of defeats the
purpose but I see your point at making a
distinction do you have a comment on
that Miss W yes just that the difference
was in 1290 that is in the policy piece
where in 1291 that's just in the purpose
and
findings so it would be read addding
policy to
it and we're not done with this by the
way even even if we pass it and nobody's
happy with 1291 we're we're not done
because uh the Senate Bill
4177 is a companion bill uh and you know
some form of that is most likely to pass
and that's going to come back over here
uh and so in in about two months we're
going to be having the same conversation
with more information and more people in
the loop so I I don't I don't see what
we're doing today as being uh the last
step I just I just see it as being the
next step um representative
walner thank
you so as I look at
um what it makes me think is that what
we have what this really is doing is
taking all the work
that chairman Pearson did in proposing
the bill and all the work of the
children and family law committee and
basically just getting rid of it and
replacing it with a million dollar and
basically saying here's a million
dollars we hope you'll do the right
thing and the
legislature is done with it um I think
that we're faced with a really serious
situation and it will be somewhat
helpful won't be the answer answer to
the problem but it'll be somewhat
helpful for the public and for people to
see that the legislature is taking it
seriously and that we're where we are
going to pass a piece of legislation
that will really outline for the
Department what is expected of them
and 1291 leaves it all up to the
department 1290
is a partnership between the department
the legislature the child advocate and
the child advocate and the department
have worked hard to come up with
something they can both agree on and
um I just feel
that this is not this is not the way
that finance committee should be moving
forward it doesn't feel fiscally respons
responsible to me to be just saying to
the department here's a million dollars
we hope you'll do the right thing um I'm
really sort of
surprised
that this kind of a suggestion would
come out of the finance committee
because it's it's sort of so unlike the
finance committee to uh just write a
blank check and hope that somebody will
do the right thing so um from that I uh
do not feel comfortable with
1291 may I may I comment and ask your
question about that um the my comment is
uh I think arguably it's more fiscally
responsible because we're talking about
a million dollars instead of you know at
least 15 new FTS and6 s million so in
terms of which one uh protects the
taxpayers more uh I I would I would say
it's 12291 I don't really think that you
know just the number that's just math um
um but to you know to your other point
um we're not the final word on this
we're we the Senate bill is going to be
given us another opportunity in a couple
of months to come back to this and there
were still some minor policy rubs I
think between OCA and the I'm still
uncomfortable that the Judiciary has
actually been fully in involved uh
division one hasn't been involved um so
um I I I would like to keep the process
moving I would like to put our
fingerprints on it to say that yes it's
a legitimate real problem for which we
want the department to take the
seriously all indications have been that
the department has taken it seriously so
so so we just have a different point of
view on that and that's okay but the but
here let me ask you a question now
though you've you've been doing this
legislative work longer than I have and
so from a simply a the perspective of
good sound discipline statutory
design do you think that it's
appropriate to put a lot of policy into
our statutes policies that might be good
but maybe more
appropriately uh put in the rules are
put into the subsequent departmental
policy I this is sort of a philosophical
question on statutory design because
this came to us I think with sort of
lacking the discipline to to to to stick
to what should be in a statute versus
what should be in a
policy I think the situation is such
that it it's going to be really
important that the
public
families other
agencies outside of state government
will be able to look
to state law to see what is required of
the department when it comes to these
outof State placements and the
placements that we make um within state
within the state um this is
probably at least to me this is probably
one of the most serious
things the state does when it takes
custody of a
child and places them in an out of home
placement it's devastating for the child
for the families and it's it's one of
the most Ser I it's just one of the most
serious things we do and to have
well-defined mechanisms within state law
on how that is going to happen and what
the oversight of that is I think is one
of the areas that is
that it is good for us to be really um
outlining what it is and I I think that
that's why the children and family law
committee sent us to us with this kind
of a detailed law um and like I said I I
just think this is probably one of the
most serious things we do as state
government to um Place children out of
their own home and we should be taking
it very seriously and we should have it
within law what our what is our
responsibility to these children to
these
families you you you'll you might be
surprised I don't disagree with any you
just said I I I just would come back to
the idea that this is a next step I I we
have been scrambling to get 1573 right
I'm still not comfortable that we've got
it right but we need to do something and
I want to I want to keep everyone moving
forward knowing that in two months we're
going to be right back at it with with s
sp4 417 so so so I sort of look at it
that way now now miss Morris the item
that you've been agreeing to with OCA
that have found its way into this
amendment uh
1290 could you just tell us in your own
words the extent to which you think
those changes have been uh implemented
in practice and in policy in the
department already that is where I will
have to bring in my subject matter
experts because I am not on the ground I
can't tell you what policies have been
changed I do know
and I believe it was prior to that but
um our staff bcbh as well as dcyf they
meet with the OCA on a weekly basis
monthly monthly um to discuss not just
this but overall programmatic changes um
but I can bring up Jeff fler who is our
director of dcyf to speak to some of
those changes that's great
okay and while we're waiting for him if
I may sir um from the office of child
Advocates standpoint Point while we have
heard the agency agree with us in theory
and in fact this bill is still largely
as drafted by the OCA with input from
Marissa hen the associate commissioner
Jeff fler and katcha Fox at a pretty
high level Marissa hen testified in
children and family law just a couple
months ago that the department was in
agreement with this entire Bill other
than the word Contracting which was
removed at this juncture while we've
heard their making changes we have
requested
repeatedly documentation of what is
being done on the ground and have not
received a single thing so while I
appreciate that we're being told it's
being done they're saying they're
sending people we say okay can we please
see the site report from a visit that
happened in August we still haven't seen
it it's almost April
so we are having a hard time endorsing
the fact that no law needs to be made
right now because they're already doing
everything apparently with no additional
funds as well it just we have not seen
the evidence of that which is troubling
since under statute we're required to
get all of that already I I think that's
a fair observation thank you for adding
that Jeff do you want
to yeah Jeff fler director
DCF yeah I think there's no question
that um OCA and DCF have been working
really well together to come up with
this legislation um we agree like uh
99% um worked very hard to compromise
and to really refine the the bill and I
think it's a good bill I think it's a
needed bill um yes we are doing a lot of
things right now to to push us forward
even before this was brought up as a as
a bill as imagined as a bill uh when we
hit the ground I hit the ground in
August that uh this has been a primary
objective to keep bring kids back home
from out of region out of state and
really make New Hampshire
self-sufficient so we can serve the most
needy kids right here at home so that's
been the bulk of our work the bulk of my
work uh here um in New Hampshire and
continue want to continue to do that I
think legislation is good though as
leadership
changes um you know philosophies change
so I think that uh having good
legislation um uh really helps the the
continuity um from commissioner to
commissioner from director to director
etc etc um we're committed to everything
we put into the to the bill up until
this amendment um as far as visits about
his
certification um it's really the
question of to getting the resources to
do that I think it's a great bill I
think there's a 99% agreement maybe 100%
agreement um and it's just a matter of
the resources to do the job well so uh
that's sort of the perspective that that
I can bring
did you hear the specific question I
made of Ms Morris to tell me of the of
the policy issues that are in
1290 to what extent have they already
been implemented by the department and
are maybe awaiting resources but from a
policy perspective you intend to have
the department doing anyways yeah I
think some just the major points is
really visiting and monitoring the at
home placements the res IAL facilities
so we have already been doing from the
DCF perspective we've been doing monthly
visits for a very long time that will
continue it will be enhanced um uh but
to today we send out we have 300 kids in
residential placement
approximately uh every one of those kids
gets a visit every month from a DCF
worker or juvenile probation officer
that's 3,000 visits a year we've been
doing that um we've been doing that
without a lot of cash to do it um travel
has gone up um uh food hotels Airline
Etc but we have been doing that um and
that will continue I think it's very
very important kids need to be monitored
just met last night with our youth
Advisory Board these are about a dozen
kids all as many are in still in
residential needing and some have been
there before so so let me ask you the
same question but from the other
direction what is in
1290 or you could just refer back to the
Pearson Amendment since you've had more
time to look at that what what is it in
there that you've not
done
um that's in the the Pearson Amendment
uh I don't know I'd have to
bow or bcbh the the certifications
um this is a uh not only talks about
dcyf what we'll do but also BC BH does
the the actually residential
certifications and I think um so you may
want to hear from them but uh is that is
that Miss Fox is that she can speak to
that I I hate to put you on the spot um
if you if you don't feel like you've had
time to answer the
question that never stops
me um I'm cuttier Fox director of the
division for Behavioral Health which
oversees the Bureau of
yeah sure I'm Kaa Fox I'm the director
of the division for Behavioral Health
which oversees the Bureau of children's
Behavioral Health I did not get the
amendment because I was out of the room
when it was handed out so I'm going to
just do this on the fly but I will tell
you that what came to light during um
August with the blood so so you did see
the Pearson Amendment though from last
Monday yes so so for the purpose of the
the question let's just sck to that and
let's keep it short if we
can the um Bureau of um Behavioral
Health has children's Behavioral Health
has been doing onsite
certification so what's changed and what
um is different and what's included in
that we now are conducting those Insight
I mean on-site um certification
processes before a child is placed in
that residential
setting so so my takeaway from that is
that the department has already
implemented and it intends to continue
to maintain implementation of the
certification requirements spelled out
in the Pearson Amendment yes okay are
are there other questions representative
if your mic is
on yeah it's quite a few
actually so
the first thing I notic so I I did get
the amendment last night and and went
through the whole thing and marked it up
compared to the bill is passed by the
house and there are a lot of changes
that um there are a lot of changes
basically it's not just the down the at
the back end but the first thing I note
that's missing is the thing we discussed
I think at our last meeting while there
are numbers in here down towards the end
in terms of Appropriations I don't see
the overall cost yet for FY uh 25 26 27
so it' be useful to have that and the
other thing that I'm still not clear on
is so this was precipitated by a single
event which was to what I've understand
and what I've heard um a big mistake was
was made by the state for like of a
better word um and we seem to be jumping
in pretty quickly uh to a
giant
solution uh which I clearly the initial
thing we saw was Overkill and clearly
it's been being worked down which is
great but it seems to me it would be
make more sense to go the other way uh
which I think is kind of what chairman
Ed Edwards was getting at you know where
are we now versus when this event
happened so we've come ways
already and what can we do incrementally
from here as opposed to uh trying to
jump in and and I I'm one of those who
considers the finance committee a policy
committee as well I don't need to go
back and forth about whether we're doing
policy or not doing policy whether it's
on our side or on the other side I think
it's that's the way the process works
here it's the way been my experiences
have been here um however this is a huge
uh policy which has you know is coming
forward and it seems like it should be a
little more incremental um given the
cost associated with it in the second
year um of a bium so I'll just leave it
at that and let you all respond to that
or not this is work session we're really
talking to each other so if so if you
want you respond to that or not no if
you want to ask a question of fact go
ahead but opinions are ours at this
point other than asking what is the
total amount of spending you're
anticipating no and I I I I I don't
think that that's we're really ready for
that do do you have you don't have a
revised draft fiscal note do you either
Mr Ripple or or or or Mr White based you
do no for um for
1290 or 12 or 1291
either yeah okay so so we we we don't
have those all right uh represent tki
thank you
listening
to what I've heard today and what I
understand there was
um an extremely
disturbing
um situation that involved children that
were placed out of state and from what I
understand the department and the office
of child
advocate were in two different places
and they were trying to work together to
ensure that they could come to some
place putting the children first and
make sure that they have the best care
possible and I know that between the
Pearson Amendment the walner amendment
um both sides have worked together and
come pretty close as we've just heard
very close I also just heard that um
due to changes in leadership and I'd
like to welcome the new director I'm not
sure I've had you here in front of our
division before um that having specific
guidelines in statute is helpful to help
with transitions in leadership and would
you say that having these kinds of
guidelines and statute are helpful to
both the office of child advocate and
the department to be able to work
together and have guidelines to ensure
that the best is being done for children
when there are out ofate
placements I think legislation's helpful
um seen it in other states where it's
really really been uh a sea change here
not so much because the work is being
done and there's a lot of camaraderie
and a lot of similarities in our
philosophies with OCA and the division
um uh but I do think that you know the
work all the work that was done to come
to compromise and to agree on so many
things um I think it's really cool and
it's something that you know is is
really a Triumph in in The Advocate
community and the and the the people who
implement the policy coming together um
it's it's really um
applaudable um to be applauded I I think
though um it should be realistic and I
think it was um we were doing these
visits anyhow um uh certification was
being done and this sort of just puts
some parameters around it
um and we've been trying to create new
programming for kids so they don't have
to go out of state or out of region um
this has all been in in the works and a
lot more work has to be done in fact I
think the real influx of dollars needs
to be in creating the new services and
the bridge funds so we can create
quality programs to BR to legitimately
bring these kids home and also prevent
in future years from them going out so I
think um we you may see us in
legislation coming forward in in in in
future months uh to talk about that to
really build a strong Continuum right
here in New Hampshire and that could
also be funded as kids come home those
dollars can be redirected to create a
stronger uh New Hampshire Continuum of
Care so I think you know it's I just
want to just say that what we came up
with prior to this amendment was strong
great guidelines there was agreement the
only difference is will we have enough
resources to carry it out thank you can
I go go go go ahead but I'm I had a hard
stop at 2:45 that's in three minutes so
uh let I'll quick go to the office of
child advocate Lissa do you I know that
this is not the ideal final product that
your department wanted which one now
though TW though both of them are not
the what the dep office of child
advocate wanted nor the Pearson
Amendment
correct um that you were pushing for
something else and do you feel that
having this kind of guidance actually um
enables the two departments to work
together concurrently and actually know
what the M the goals are in the end and
it's better than where we're at now
thank you for your question
representative tki absolutely
1290 does reflect a majority of the
agreement M ments that we have had since
last August um when the bledo incident
came to light I would just like to
clarify though um bledo was the incident
that set this off bledo is not a
one-time incident it is not an outlier
we can tell you about kids that have
been tased in facilities and park I'm
going to cut you off because that's
outside the scope of the question and
and I'm just I I I'm trying to get us to
a conclusion here so so uh we're we're
we're and I think you actually said that
in testimony the first day we listened
to 1273 so um I'm I'm going to call a
fem minute recess and we're going to
come back and we're going to vote on
this okay so we're in recess till
e
call us out of recess um on um 1573 the
last item of the day I would like to
propose that uh Mr Ripple that we send
1291 back over to Os or that we get
ready to do that with the idea that
there is
language
on on on page lines 9 7 through n page 4
7 to9 any placement of a child outside
of of New England shall require the
approval of the division of DCF director
prior to the placement with specific
findings of the need for the placement I
I I would like that added to a new
version of
okay
okay at at this point I I would I would
like a
motion to um adopt Amendment
1291 with the qualifier that we're going
to add that page four language about the
director is there a
motion representative Earth moves
it
second okay so if any further discussion
representative priest yes I would like
to go on the record and and voice my
opinion that the amendment
1290 was
was the result of both of these
departments and the previous legislative
committee working together and
addressing this problem and it spells
out the responsibilities and the duties
of everyone and I think this is far more
comprehensive than
1291 thank you thank you I think you're
going to see that again in Senate Bill
417 and and we've already heard that the
Department's implementing the the the
policies so and may I just again I we
shouldn't assume what we're going to be
seeing from the Senate we should be
sending over the best bill that
addresses the problem that we have and
this is a as has been stated before this
is a very serious problem that needs to
be addressed it's not one occurrence
it's been happening a lot and we need to
have something that's spelled out so the
department will know what is expected of
them and what we will be seeing as a
result of their work and this is not
done in
1291 thank you representative
walner thank
you today the director from the
Department the director of um division
of Children and Families has a come
before us today and said
that he feels it's a needed
Bill he he is here representing the
department and feeling like he needs
this kind of a piece of legislation in
order to be sure that this work is
carried out the way it needs to be and
um I think that he made a great point in
that leadership
changes and we've seen it so often at
the department where leadership does
change and that needing this kind of a
of some in a bill in
legislation in statute is what we need
so that the department knows the
direction the legislature wants them to
take with um the oversight of these
children in out of home
placement so I heard that testimony and
uh Mr uh flasher is going to be around
for a while he's already implemented the
changes Miss fox has already implemented
changes so we're we're we're good until
there is a change in leadership uh I I
don't know that we have one
forecasted um so I think we have time to
to get this right this is still not the
right bill to me it's 15 new FTE this is
just way too much particularly when the
testimony said that we're going to come
back with another bill later to spend
more money on bring and make making sure
that kids never leave the state well you
can't keep spending 15 FTE at a time and
still have the resources available to do
what's the right thing in the first
place which is just keep people home um
so what we didn't ask Mr flasher and I
did that didn't ask out of a concern
over time is uh if he'd ever seen any
legisl any situations in which
legislative legislation was so
restrictive it undermined the discretion
and the ability of management to be
flexible and I'll just say from my
perspective having been in the military
I have seen where topown commands are so
restrictive that they really over time
don't age well and commands are doing
things that they shouldn't do because
they've been told in regulation that
they must be done so um so go ahead yeah
this is just really a question I have of
I guess you or maybe maybe um
Mr Ripple about
in 1291 the appropriation is to the
Department of Health and Human Services
and does that mean that the court is not
there are no changes in any kind of
requirements by the court and there's no
appropriation to the court is that
correct I I believe that's correct
yes um the if I'm not mistaken at the
bottom of page seven no she this one the
short one the short Amendment oh the
short Amendment
h i I think that's a good
observation all right so is there any
further discussion on 1291 with the
verbal um modification to include line
seven go ahead I just want to point out
one thing it may be insignificant but
it's I believe the uh statement of
purpose and findings in 1291 was
supposed to be ident identical to that
in 129h and it is not it's an older
version um so there are a few minor
differences here uh for example if you
look at 1290 there are some RSA
references on line six and seven if you
go down to line 19 of page one it refers
to an acceptable primary reason for
placement in a residential facility so
there are some minor differences that
aren't aren't reflect could you go ahead
and fix those because the guidance I
gave was that that they were supposed to
be identical I can do that Y and and one
of the things that also I think got
dropped from the Pearson amendment was
the first
line around
qualified
the I I I thought we wanted to go ahead
and keep the
qualified
clarification go ahead um so the
qualified was really throughout the text
of the
bill and and that's not in the purpose
and findings so that's why that line
didn't but I wanted to keep it do we not
need to keep that we don't need to keep
no we don't okay great all right so do
have since you made the the motion I'm
getting ready to take a vote because
we're we're running out of time and I
think we've discussed this and we know
our positions at this point so
representative Earth you made a motion
to include the additional language will
you update it so that it's an identical
purpose and
finding
do do you second okay representing
walner I guess my my question is one of
of the chair about I know that we have
on a couple of other occasions today
um made amendments sort of on the fly to
amendments um and we agreed with them
this one to me feels like this is such
an important bill that I'm wondering if
we are going to get an opportunity to
see this final Amendment that's going to
be voted on and have a final vote so
that any vote taken here at this point
would be s a preliminary until we've
actually had a chance to see final
Amendment so like the other two the
implication was that we were going to
validate that they were consistent with
our vote and and the default was that if
they were consistent then we would
accept them uh if they weren't and and I
think I think the rational Assumption of
what's been done in division 3 before is
if if there's an error we'll fix it okay
and and that is the same with this
we're going to get a chance to look at
it beforehand I don't consider this a
preliminary vote I consider this the
vote and if the um language comes back
as we are voting on it then the vote
stands if there's an error we'll address
the error and when will we do that well
we'll do it during the finance committee
because uh we're going to distribute
these amendments U hopefully by off copy
earlier rather than later but no later
than our voting on them in the full
finance committee so will these be on
are these on the agenda for Tuesday
Tuesday afternoon I I don't I don't know
the
agenda I I I I I I wanted them to be
because I thought today was our last day
to do our our work and I wanted them
over to the full finance committee Mr
chair yeah so just so to reiterate what
I just heard you say right relative to
what the amendment is we are taking
wholesale from
129h SE lines one page one lines one
through the bottom and then page two
lines one through five which is all of
section one inclusive and then adding
just those three lines from page four 7
8 and N into one combined Amendment
verbatim and that's and then adding
section two which was the
appropriation yes okay I I I'm I'm
trying to clarify what we're seeing
because we don't have it in front of us
physically but it's there in pieces
across multiple sheets of paper I I I
would entertain a motion to interim
study I'm I'm trying I'm trying to keep
some momentum and keep things moving
without it being study right now if that
was an appropriate
motion um let let's let's let's take a
let's take a vote on this and then uh
we'll take a vote on the other Amendment
and then we can consider whether or not
an interim study is a more appropriate
motion representative Lon um thank you
Mr chairman I think possibly the reason
why the entire thing didn't come out the
second to last sentence um in that
section one is just talking about the
Appropriations so of everything except
for the second to last sentence that
says to allow for the expansion of these
services and talks about the effective
date um I would think that bringing
everything except for that one sentence
that is um is the right right way to do
that that says to allow for the
expansion of these services to be
implemented in a thoughtful and detail
detailed
manner so without correct that would
probably not be in this amendment would
end with residential
setting on page two line
one do you have
that yes I do everything before
uh to allow on page two line one
yes all right represent walner yes could
I just ask Kevin could you maybe um
provide us with a list of all the things
that are supposed we're supposed to be
looking for in this amendment that we're
going to
see thank
you any any
further it does
good is that a work session or
executive AR aren't we executing all
these bills on Tuesday at 1 o00 so it's
an exact session in 1573 it does not
include 1573 it does include a lot of
these bills but not that one sorry 1573
is on the is on the
calendar 1593 oh 1573 I take it back
sorry so so did you get the record
straight 1573 is listed for exec session
on the 26th
yeah okay
okay all right so we'll do a show of
hands on a modification to um uh
Amendment 1291 as described uh if if
you're in favor raise your
hand if you're opposed raise your
hand okay
54 okay so now uh we should consider
1290 which is a some modifications from
the Pearson Amendment uh that we saw on
Monday this one has the Appropriations
in it is there any further discussion on
1290 I'll make a motion okay I move that
we 1290 be ought to pass okay uh is
there a second second um so um since
this is an amendment is there anyone who
Minds to show hands on this if if you're
in favor of of passing uh Amendment 1290
show a
hands if you're opposed to 1290 show a
hands so that's a 4 five
vote okay and then we need to talk about
the underlying bill so with the
amendment coming is there a motion for
OTP a of 1573 with the modified 1291
I'll move 1573 with uh modified 1291
Amendment modified 1291 is there a
second okay first and second would you
record the vote when you have a
chance represent
[Music]
Stringham so this is House Bill
1573 Amendment
1291 further
amended uh to be to be determined
uh made by Earth and seconded by whole
is that right yes thank you all right
representative Leon
yes representative F yes representative
hle yes representative Wier walner no
Representative tersi no Stringham votes
no representative Priest No chairman
Edwards
yes vote being 5 to four uh the motion
carries I I have 308 I'm I apologize to
anyone who believed me when I said
245 um got a lot done got a lot of
agreement not everything but uh but we
did get a lot of agreement so I think
we're ready for
Finance exec session um any final words
of wisdom Mr Ripple and anyone from the
committee okay with that we're adjourned
so
for